This last step is growing customers for the web/mobile channels.
Now if you remember we started here on the left. We didn't earn and paid media.
We got customers, acquired them, and activated them.
We've kept them trying to keep the churn to a minimum.
And now we're going to grow customers with the series of activities just like in the physical channel.
Can we up-sell, can we next-sell, can we cross-sell,
and can get referrals that will get us a viral loop.
One of the most important metrics to think about now that we have an end-to-end funnel
is something called lifetime value and a lifetime value LTV is not your lifetime
but your customer's lifetime.
How much will they spend with you and your company from the beginning to the very end.
And this is kind of an interesting idea because most startups and most founders
are focused on how do I get them to activate here?
But for you to be a successful company and actually thinking about
how much you could spend on them over here, you need to understand--
can I get them to spend more and more over time and how to keep them
longer and longer by reducing churn.
So one of the interesting equations for every startup is that
lifetime value needs to be greater than customer acquisition cost.
Seems intuitively obvious but what you want to make sure
is the amount of money you're collecting over here is bigger than the customer acquisition cost
to remember the amount of money you're spending from here to here.
That was the customer acquisition cost, CAC, here.
So lifetime value needs to be greater than customer acquisition cost.
And as you get more familiar with your company and start talking to investors,
the real interesting thing is what is this ratio?
For example, in SAS software, some investors think that number should be 3>1.
In Telecom, it might be something else but the key idea is you are now not just focused
on the initial purchase but you're focused on the lifetime value.
If you have world's most perfect business model, investors would love to see
this number much bigger than this number and so what you want to look for
is a well-balanced model that takes into account how much you need to acquire customers
but how much ultimately you'll extract from them over the lifetime.
What's the lifetime?
That really is up to you and your investors on how many years you calculate lifetime value.
Some use 3 years, some use 5--that's a question that you and your investors will discuss.
This acquisition cost versus lifetime value discussion really is a balancing act.
So what are some of the balancing acts?
Well, in the customer acquisition cost, if all of a sudden, you could get a viral loop going,
well, that decreases your cost of acquisition.
If in fact, your conversion rate between acquisition activation could be increased.
Again, it decreases your customer acquisition cost.
If you could do in physical channels, telesales or inside sales versus having a direct sales force,
Again, your CAC declines. The idea is what can you do to make this very efficient?
And therefore, also, on lifetime value, how do you reduce churn and attrition in keeping customers?
Do you have scalable pricing? Are you cross-selling and up-selling a lot?
Can you expand your product line?
And again, are you getting a viral loop and referral loop from happy and satisfied customers
telling others word of mouth and so this is a balancing game,
and for first time entrepreneurs who are focused here,
it's really important to think about customer acquisition cost and a lifetime value.